story time in my old apartment complex  my upstairs neighbor got a new boyfriend  and we could hear it let me tell you we  could hear it it'd be super awkward  because at like two in the morning six  in the morning i just hear her yelling  like oh my god oh my god i had a group  chat with our apartment and their  apartment because it was a duplex so it  was just the two of us i found this old  screenshot oh my goodness yo this is  awkward i'm not sure who's been loudly  hooking up at 6 a.m but the entire  apartment is shaking if i wake up to oh  my god one more time when i'm dead ass  mid-sleeping i'm going to go straight to  heaven and get him myself anyways go you  but we can all hear you this girl she  tries to compare it to playing music and  watching tv